thus far we've talked about two
different ways that you've persuaded
alumni to give back in their time in
committing to service and also in their
treasure and donating to Yale I wonder
is there a difference in the way that
you asked for those two different kinds
of philanthropy do you change the way
that you approach the issue change the
way that you send out contact
information does it vary at all it does
and I have to say I think I'm really bad
at fundraising it's not something I like
to do I signed up to be a class agent
because I'm married to a classmate and
someone came to me and said okay we've
got about 12 couples who are married to
each other our class would you be the
people who go out and ask them for money
so I'm actually asking people in a
similarly situated and some of whom I
know I'm very profound tree about it I
don't do a good job so but I when I do
engage in the conversation I have the
conversation I talked about before I
some people are much better at that and
I am passionate about the cause and
actually as I've been more involved with
you it's much easier for me to ask for
money because I can talk about the
things i just talked about i can talk
about the reasons why I think it's
important they'd have impact but it's
it's much different it's so easy to ask
someone you know the person who asked me
just called me up and said you know
you've been in i lived in dallas at the
time you've been in dallas for a year
we've got this Yale Club we need
somebody to do the vice president
programming will you do it you know and
it's sao that first of all that makes
you feel good right will you do this job
I'll give you a title and it's easy to
ask people I think to do something
something with time and talent
especially because you can also frame it
and say all I need is you you know this
many hours on this one project or I
needed to commit to get on a path to do
what I've done and spend 14 years you
know engaged in a real way but I think
and you have the commonality of yellow
of course with with the ladder even more
easily than than for money it's easy to
say hey you know we already have this
connection that's why I'm talking to you
in the first place people tend to people
tend to want to be involved they can see
what it's going to look like no
so I think it's very different so
actually related to commonality I read
the article that you published in the
yellow alumni magazine the call for
service right and one of the things that
you suggested was that individual or
alumni should donate two groups that
they were associated with while they
were on campus they're the political
union or yell women groups that they
identify with what role do you think
that identity plays in asking alums to
give back either in time or rent Roger
well I think that's what we've
discovered is very important because it
used to be that the aya we had classes
and clubs regional clubs and then
graduate professional school affiliation
and frankly we were much more focused on
the classes in clubs it was a much more
college Yale College oriented
organization and there were people who
love that I was very involved with my
class and I love my classmates and I
come back to reunions and that's great I
got involved in a regional club because
somebody asked me to but we were leaving
out a lot of people we were leaving out
people who didn't feel as though that
they fit in because of their actual
identity their you know their racial
identity or their religious identity or
something that was more definable about
them that you could maybe see or
understand when you interacted with them
and people who wanted to connect because
they were in a singing group or they
were with the political union I think
part of what we're doing is instead of
imposing a way to connect on people
saying how do you want to connect how do
you want to be involved what was what
were you passionate about passionate
about when you are here at Yale we can
find it you know would you be interested
in helping us find a way for you to
connect back through that passion and
it's been very successful we have this
[ __ ] what we call the shared interest
groups which reflect both the sort of
interest and identity that people have
and there's there's over a hundred of
them it's it's really it's almost more
than we can handle because people
responded so to that so I think that
that makes the difference